I very honored to kick off the kick off
the quarter so what I'm going to be
talking about today or getting to
eventually is the idea is that kind of a
proposal for a system that would help
people talk about and converse about and
disclose flaws in the published research
record just to start off with some
groundbreaking news on it will shock you
over millions of academic papers
published some of them are not correct
okay so the question is how do we do
things sorry
well I don't know I hope not but
everything's probabilistic the our goal
sort of broadly speaking right is we
want like more of these papers to be
correct and fewer of them to be
incorrect so we can actually learn
things the scientists and is like
consumers of research in the public that
are accurate so what I'm gonna be
talking about today just is first to
give some background about what's but
really call like a crisis of credibility
in empirical social science right now
I'm some of you might have heard a lot
about this some of you might have heard
almost nothing about it so I'm gonna
kind of talk about this tell like how it
works why is it that social science is
in such bad shape right now in my
opinion anyway I'm gonna talk about some
existing efforts that are really great
that are trying to address some of the
problems I'm gonna talk about and then
I'm gonna talk about kind of a proposed
additional effort that I don't think
will solve all problems but I think
might help solve some problems that kind
of plague the status quo right now
and it can help accomplish that goal of
more research is correct less research
is incorrect so and in there will be a
thrilling personal story of a sort
anyway that that you mentioned so first
I think the title of this really famous
paper it was from 2005 really kind of
summarizes basically the state of the
world we're in right now pretty
accurately it's not just like some
academic papers are false is probably
actually the case that a majority of
academic papers are false this is bad
our job is not to be this way we want to
produce research that is correct and
there's I'm gonna talk in a second about
why this is but this original paper in
2005 just did some basically careful
math
understand okay based on the way that we
know scientists do their work and the
way we know publishing works which I'll
get into in a second what percent of
papers are probably correct and the
answer to arrive does is most or not
recently
this was just a few months ago there was
this really ambitious effort by so folks
at a non-profit called the open science
collaboration based in the university or
around the University of Virginia and
have science labs a psychology labs
across the country or they tried to kind
of evaluate this claim empirically and
they said okay let's go to some really
prominent psychology journals that
journals that like important findings
that have a lot of credibility
associated with them let's go read a
hundred psychology studies and then just
replicate them exactly so you read a
study and it says if you show people the
color red then they you know are more
likely to use this word or something or
if you talk to people in a certain way
about let's say another group there'll
be less prejudice towards that group and
so they said let's just do exactly what
these people did to see if the discovery
they supposedly made or their theory is
is actually right now I'm just doing
exactly what they did replication what
they found when they just did the exact
same studies that are in these
prestigious journals is that most of the
time they could not actually replicate
those studies so consistent with this
these theories from about ten years ago
it actually does seem like in social
science journals right now probably most
of what we read is not true
so I would say this is about as worse
like we can't really be failing any more
than this and so like why is this the
case why are we failing so there's this
really great I think it's like two or
three page little semi satirical paper
by this anonymous skeptic kind of critic
of science yeah so they talked about
this in the paper it's possible that
there's a lot of reasons why something
might not replicate it might not be true
it might not just like not be very
generalizable that's right so that I
would definitely put under the heading
of like you know in some sense
it's you know it depends on the question
you're trying to answer is it like is
the original paper wrong or is it just
like not very useful in some of their
circumstances we can't be sure but
that's kind of the evidence we have
right now in any case so some reasons
why that might be the case why it is
that we might not be very good at
producing accurate knowledge are
summarized in this very humourous
pyramid I'm inspired by Dante's Inferno
by this anonymous critic of science
neuro sceptic he calls the nine circles
of scientific hell and this is kind of a
chronicle of some of the practices that
lead to this state of affairs and I'm
going to talk about a couple of them in
detail the first is something that has
gotten a lot of a lot of coverage
recently and this is the idea of what's
called p-value fishing or P hacking and
here's how this works when you do for
those of you have not done a empirical
social science study when you do a study
quite often what you do is you say okay
I have some theory about the world and
let's say I have this pill that's gonna
reduce blood pressure and I gave I did
an experiment I gave let's say this half
of the room is randomly seeded on this
half you guys get the blood pressure
medicine you guys get the sugar pill and
now I'm gonna measure your blood
pressure and say hey it turns out the
people that I gave the blood pressure
medicine to have slightly lower blood
pressure is a success okay well how do I
know you know there's a 50/50 chance
that one half of the room is going to
have lower blood pressure than another
how do I know that really this side of
the room has such lower blood pressure
it's really unlikely that I just happen
to put the low blood pressure people on
this side well we got this thing called
a p-value which is rigorously stated the
probability that if this blood pressure
medicine didn't work your blood pressure
really would be as low as it is so the
idea is I say you're a skeptic you say
there's no way your pill works I say
well if you are right there's only a 1%
chance that this side of the room if we
just randomly sorted people we'd get
people on the side of the room that have
such lower blood pressure than this side
so that's a p-value I'd say that's a
p-value of 0.01 and in the world of
academia
generally speaking the threshold we use
for kind of over the bar a finding that
is worthy of note is a p-value of 0.05
doesn't mean something is true if the
p-values below 0.05 it just means it's
kind of clear to this arbitrary bar of
this this is the kind of evidence that a
skeptic of your theory
would not expect to see the problem is
and if you think about this imagine a
world and I'm gonna explain this graphic
as I go this is from a paper by some
Simonson Nelson and Simmons in 2013 they
have this idea where they say well you
know we we see that what a lot of people
are doing is they say well I know my
colleagues I want to publish a paper get
a line on my CV I know my colleagues
want to see a p-value below 0.05 that's
the bar and let's say I did this blood
pressure study I put you guys over here
and you over here and the p-value is
like point oh six I say man you know
that's not enough in the academic court
of opinion to get my CV line which I
need so what am I going to do
well what I'm gonna do and what they
show a lot of people seem to be doing is
they say well you know maybe this blood
pressure medicine doesn't work for
everybody but maybe it works for let's
say people under 30 and so I look at
just the people under 30 okay no like
the p-value there's like point - okay
well maybe it works like just for men
okay no it doesn't work for men for
women and sepal looking and say well
there was this one person who I know
didn't really take their medicine and
you like look at the date a lot of
different ways and finally you find a
way you look at the data and the p-value
is like point oh four you say AHA oh of
course that's I mean all along I thought
that if we just look at men under 30 we
would see this effect and indeed when we
look at that subgroup there's an effect
then you have a paper pill reduces blood
pressure for men under 30 okay so this
is the kind of thing that people
suspected was going on that you can kind
of keep looking in the data until you
get that significant effect which is
troublesome I should say because even if
your blood pressure medicine worked for
nobody if you just keep on cutting the
data in a lot of ways you're gonna
eventually find something like that so
what they said is well you know it's
hard to in any particular case and know
this is going on but at the level of the
entire community you can actually get
some sense of it and they found some
pretty disturbing evidence of exactly
this so on this graph what you're seeing
on the red line is imagine that if we
have these p-values if if imagine that
experiment I just described this blood
pressure medicine that doesn't work is
done like 10,000 times in every
University in the country and then we
just collect all the p-values from all
those honest experiments if that blood
pressure medicine doesn't doesn't work
what we're gonna see is basically
because it's a probability just uniform
distribution we're just
as many people use 0 at 0.01 basically
5% of the p-values will be below 0.05 4
percent will be 11-point o 4 etc just
uniform distribution on the other hand
suppose that this medicine actually does
work not everyone's gonna find that
magic below 0.05 but more people are
gonna find lower p-values so that's that
line in green so basically if we have
some chance if the kind of effect is
real and we have some chance of
detecting it you're going to see more
people use kind of sorts queuing such
that there's more closer to zero but
instead when you look at a lot of
literature's and psychology and even in
medicine what you find is the opposite
which makes no sense statistically and
one of the only ways you can get it is
if researchers are doing what I just
described if they say well I have this
data and I'm just gonna kind of like
keep on looking at it in different ways
and as soon as I managed to find a
comparison that just eats over that
threshold below 0.05 I'm gonna say aha
that's my paper and then write a paper
around that and when you collect all the
p-values and this I think I forget which
this was they had on their blog data
Coolatta you see you see you see
evidence like this yeah so would this
still be the case if people weren't
insight were accurate and they were
actually pursuing things that didn't
have an effect sorry yeah so sort of
maybe heard that so the red line is the
null hypothesis is true that is to say
medicine doesn't work that's what the
p-values would look like uniform
distribution if the null hypothesis is
false and there is some effect then you
see the green and so really what we
should see in the worst case is that
kind of flat and and if as we start to
study true things which I started to see
look more lower p-values but like what
we see is the opposite of what you see
like which like makes no sense unless
researchers are doing that's what they
call have P hacking and what's in blue
is actually like an empirical observed
kind of P curve they call it in some
academic literature so what so so that's
not good
so another this is a recent study by one
of my colleagues in the political
economy group so he looked at there's
kind of just where you can sort of see
this even happening more directly so
they did is they said you know there's
this cool competitive grant competition
in psychology there's one in political
science to where
you can do is say I this idea for these
experiments they can be done in
Mechanical Turk you have people so read
some text see if it changes their
attitude say and what people would do is
say well here's my idea for an
experiment I'm gonna show people let's
say one of five different stories and
then ask them questions about that story
did you find it persuasive did you like
it whatever else let's say I'm really
boring study like that and then then
they say when they send the proposal
like here's what it is we're going to do
here's what it is we want to test and in
order to like get the money for the
proposal you have to like actually say
what it is you want to do with the data
and in this particular case how it
worked is that the people actually went
when you kind of win the proposal this
group actually does the research for you
so when you win they say we're gonna go
run your questions on our pool of
subjects and run your experiment for you
give you back the data and then you get
to go publish it pretty good right well
that also means is that these authors
might they working with the people who
ran this repository Neil and his
co-authors could go back and say well
let's look at these original plans
researchers had and how often do they
actually follow what they said oh I'm
gonna look at say if people like story a
better than the story B and that's
that's my hypothesis and what they find
is that when you look in the papers um
it looks pretty different than what
people said they originally intended
kind of consistent with that story of
after the fact looking for the kind of
good looking results so you find that
when you look at all the tests that are
not reported that people planned they
said to do those usually are not
significant they don't meet that magic
point of five threshold but there's
other ways of looking at the data like
well if we look at this other question
that I asked and I look at this other
group then I do see something and that's
what makes it into the final paper and
so you can actually see individual
studies doing this systematically so
this is kind of a problem if you're if
you're already depressed don't make you
a little more depressed so this sort of
is sort of dishonest in some way at the
level of individuals so we say oh all
along I thought this now imagine that
everybody actually is honest
we're just lazy that's what the next the
next issue is about this is called
partial publication so the idea here is
imagine that again there's those 10,000
universe
cities around the country all doing
their experiment they all split the room
in half give half the people who right
push them blood pressure medicine half
don't as I said 5% are gonna come up
with the magic answer that this in fact
does reduce blood pressure even if it
doesn't okay so we're gonna have these
hundreds of people across the country
who find this result even though the
vast majority of people are going to get
the truth and say no this probably
doesn't work well how academic
publishing works is when you have a
crazy idea and it's wrong then you know
that happens all the time you sort of
move on to the next project so all the
people who they had this blood pressure
medicine they gave it to this side of
the room didn't do any better
oh well lots of things don't reduce
blood pressure let's move on but for the
5% of people that erroneously found that
it did work those people are gonna say
wow I found something really cool and I
want to go publish it and so as a reader
as someone looking at academic journals
the only things people bother to write
up and send in and they get published
are the things that report a crazy idea
that's true and all in when those same
crazy ideas when they're tested by lots
of other people when they're false we
never hear about it so you as a reader
might say wow there's 500 studies
showing that this blood pressure
medicine worked
that's great evidence that I should take
it really what you're missing is the
population of when thousands and
thousands of other people didn't find
that it worked they didn't feel like
they were gonna spend the time to tell
you that and you see this in the
literature where when you look right at
0.05 there's way more p-values across
lots and lots of papers that are below
this point of 5 threshold and as soon as
you get above that people are much less
likely to publish their results so as a
whole even if we're all individually
honest that kind of laziness our taste
for kind of interesting results or crazy
ideas that are proven right instead of
wrong means that collectively we kind of
rendered dishonest answers so this is
all kind of troubling these are at least
some of the reasons we don't have a good
sense of how widespread all these
different practices are is what extent
each of them contributes to the kind of
lack of replicability of the literature
in general but all of them probably due
to some extent so there's a lot of
efforts right now and over the last 10
years especially a lot of people have
been thinking about what are ways in
which we can try to kind of combat this
and I'm going to just briefly mention a
few ideas out there
so one this is one of the older ideas of
the idea of making replication data
available so if you think about those
studies where I showed people five
different stories ask them if they liked
it they were persuaded and I just
reported well you compare this one story
to this other story on this one you know
that selective reporting if you have to
post all your data people could
hypothetically go back to it and say
wait a minute what about all these other
conditions or alternatively wait you
said the blood pressure medicine worked
for men under 30 but when I look at your
whole data file I see it didn't work for
anybody else so the things that you
might not want to mention in your
journal article let's say if you have to
post your whole replication data file
now all of a sudden kind of another
person kind of that you're opened up to
that transparency another thing that
another idea that's out there the
federal government actually recently
instituted this this idea of a registry
of all studies so the idea is before I
even start my blood pressure study one
of my 10,000 blood pressure studies
across the country did we imagine I have
to actually go to the government and say
hey by the way I'm starting to do this
study of this blood pressure medicine
and if I ever want to get it published
or if I'm a drug company get my drug
approved I have to show that before I
even started the study that I did that
and that's a great idea because that
means when the 500 people go to the
government and say hey I have this study
showing the blood pressure medicine
works
the government says okay well before I
recommend that people take this pill I
want to go look in the registry and say
how many other people tested this
hypothesis I never heard from and
there's a lot of them let's go like call
them up and say well what did you find
how come we never heard from you and see
what the truth is another idea is what's
called a pre analysis plan so just like
there was that example of the proposal
made to the granting agency people
there's a new norm that people should
before they do an experiment actually
say here's the group that I'm going to
compare here's the hypothesis that I'm
testing and that way kind of guard
against the perception that oh after the
fact you just picked you just picked on
the basis of which results look best you
can say no in advance this is what I
meant and that way it's much less likely
that whatever significant result you're
showing me is just the result of looking
for lots and lots and lots of potential
chance effects and what I want to kind
of talk about today though is the idea
that that this transparency is really
good but it's only half of the puzzle
is it is kind of a necessary condition
that we are able to understand more
about the process behind published
research - so that like kind of mistakes
be they're innocent or not so innocent
can be detected on but if the
replication data for a paper let's say
is posted that means the mistakes or
fraud or whatever else could be detected
but just the fact that it's out there in
public doesn't actually do the detecting
somebody actually has to go do that and
so what I'm gonna talk about is kind of
a personal story related to this it's
made me come up with some ideas for some
new ways in which we could not just
basically take all the transparent
material that's out there and make sure
that people are actually using it kind
of auditing the public record and sort
of the research record and seeing okay
the studies that are out there
can we actually believe them you know to
do that I'm gonna talk about a personal
story that running that I had or I think
the lawyers told me I need to say in my
professional opinion that I ran into the
the last thing in this in this pyramid
which is which is falsification of data
so about two or three years ago the or
actually me start earlier those of you
were here in California November 2008
there was this Proposition 8 which was a
proposition banning gay marriage in
California that passed much to the
surprise of many people it was pulling
like it was gonna be defeated but
instead the kind of populist voted in
this kind of anti-gay way and the Los
Angeles LGBT Center this nonprofit
organization in Los Angeles where prop 8
actually passed to their surprise in
Liberal LA County said we really want to
understand why it is that people are
kind of voting against us and so they
started sending people door-to-door
having conversations in out of liberal
neighborhoods that nevertheless voted
for prop 8 to say now why did you vote
for Prop 8 and going door to door having
conversations with people and they
started to develop an approach that they
thought was effective at reducing
people's prejudice towards gay people
and making them more open towards gay
marriage with the idea that this might
be on the ballot again these you know
people they were talking to might have
gay relatives or gay friends kind of
reduced kind of the prejudice that they
thought was animating this vote and they
did something not just that was really a
unique thing in politics they did
something that's even more unique among
people working in politics which is they
said well we have what we think is a
good idea about how to accomplish
something but we want to know is it
actually a good idea or is this just a
bad crazy idea and so they contacted
academics and said we want to have this
thing that we thing we've developed this
kind of conversation where ultimately
they got to is asking people about out
of the marriages that they had or the
love in their life and trying to get
them to see how gay people felt the same
way about the marriages they wanted to
have they wanted to see is this the kind
of thing is it that actually works and
so they worked with a researcher in
their neighborhood his name is Mike
liqueur he was a graduate student at
UCLA just down the road from their
headquarters and he did an experiment
where just like with the blood pressure
medicine instead of giving you the blood
pressure medicine and you the sugar pill
he sent Canvassers he had the canvassers
for the Los Angeles LGBT Center go
door-to-door and deliver the blood
pressure medicine so to speak that has
have the conversation the LA LGBT Center
had developed or instead have an
unrelated conversation about recycling
so these these canisters are going
toward a door and now we have a
treatment group random randomly assigned
that sort of identical at the beginning
but now one group has this kind of
treatment of the conversation one group
has the control group of we know they
the same kind of people they can they'll
open the door their home on a Saturday
morning but we're not gonna kind of give
them this treatment and then he went
back allegedly and surveyed these people
to say okay well what do you think about
gay marriage now and the results of this
were reported in science and they're
really interesting and I'm not gonna go
answer them too much but the kind of
banner finding was that a conversation
with a gay person increased support for
gay marriage very very dramatically and
we're over that this effect lasted so
social science is full of apparent
effects on people's attitudes towards
people and groups and issues but almost
always what we find is that if you say
read some persuasive text today and you
say oh I that really convinces me you
totally forget about that by the next
day
effects on attitudes decay very rapidly
what was unique about this is something
about conversations with a gay canvasser
specifically we're memorable it seemed
like forever so a year later the people
who got that conversation or more
supportive of gay marriage and the
people who had the recyling conversation
so this is a really cool study and it
kind of overturned a lot of kind of what
I had always believed in what we being
graduate students and social science
always learn that you can't really
change people's attitudes with kind of a
10-minute conversation about something
like this and so I said something really
special is going on here and I want to
really understand why and so I sort of
started working on a follow-up study and
the because of some other work that I
had done this group got in contact with
me and they wanted to do a follow-up
study on some of their work about used
towards transgender people
with gay marriage legal they said well
now the next frontier is the T and LGBT
and so we started planning a study and
in the course of this I wanted to look
back at the original study to say well I
need to kind of plan some things about
how the study is going to go I need to
know how much precision to expect what
the response rates will be and in the
course of looking through this data this
replication data that it's required to
be posted I found some things that were
pretty weird so here's one example of I
think the first thing that I found so
there is this one measure in the study
called a feeling thermometer and what a
feeling thermometer is as I asked you
imagine there's this thing called the
feeling thermometer and it goes from
zero which means very cold to hundred
which means very warm and fifty which
means like lukewarm and you know in the
middle and I want to ask you on that
scale how do you feel about gay people
and this is a notoriously terrible
survey question because it doesn't mean
anything and so what you find is that
when you ask people these questions if
you ask the same person the same
question on Monday and Tuesday and
Wednesday and Thursday they like give
you a totally different answer every day
because they have no idea how to take
this thing which is this kind of vague
feeling they have about gay people and
map it on to this zero to 100 scale
people are bad with numbers they're even
worse at translating their feelings into
into numbers and so I knew going in okay
this is the kind of item that's going to
be really bad you're gonna see a lot of
people and you also see on surveys total
Jokers all the time people say a hundred
one day zero the next and there's all
these kind of ways in which the survey
data are kind of crap that I'm used to
seeing never but what you actually saw
is when you look at the people in the
study when you look at what people said
when they were interviewed one week and
then when they were interviewed only a
few days
later people's responses were very very
stable and across something like 10,000
people who are supposedly in this study
nobody did those Joker things that I
know people do on surveys where they
give a really different answer and so
the time I sort of thought okay well
this is pretty weird and I sort of
started thinking about this and was like
okay I might have stumbled this paper
almost no nothing from political science
ever gets published in this journal
science which is like the most
prestigious to academic journal which
this paper was not only was really
prestigious in my field and changed my
thinking a lot
it was influencing what real world
people do there was a referendum coming
up in Ireland where they were trying to
use this study to try to convince people
to vote for this referendum and make it
such that there was full marriage
equality in Ireland there were also lots
of other groups that were trying to
adapt this technique in door-to-door
I'll give you an example climate groups
were thinking okay one of the one of the
findings of the study was it has to be a
gay person to have this long-lasting
effect can't be a straight person so
they were thinking well what kind of
messengers can we use do we need to get
people from like low-lying areas whose
houses are gonna be underwater to go
talk to people in the rest of town and
say hey remember me like when you think
climate change think of me the person
whose house is gonna be underwater this
this study spawned lots and lots of lots
and lots of different people thinking
even this morning on the train I got an
email from somebody that said an animal
rights group that was thinking about
sort of using this before what happened
happened and so I realized this is not
just the kind of thing we're
intellectually it's important to get
this right there's like thousands of
people around the world who are actually
trying to use this thing and I might
know something like really relevant to
the thing there's been in their time on
so what does one do in such situations
so what I did is talking to say okay I'm
gonna grad student I have this like
suspicion I'm not really sure about it
you know I think I know how serve a
state a state is supposed to look so I
talked to a bunch of senior colleagues
in my field we had conferences I would
give talks to other universities and I
would say hey I found these patterns
like what do you think that what do you
think that I should do and what I heard
from basically everyone was very
surprising to me and what they told me
is that I should do nothing they said
just move past it and
tend that you never saw this because
it's not a clear case you sort of have
these suspicions you have better things
to do which I just felt like was really
not responsible and what they told me is
but look whenever you criticize the
publish record in this way you know
there's a lot of papers criticizing
other papers and if you have sort of a
new theory or a new explanation and you
can show hey look at how smart I am I
have this new theory for this paper out
there that's a really respected normal
thing and about academia we've just
adversarial interactions but it's kind
of really different when what you're
doing and work a critique you have kind
of borders into this territory that this
critique definitely would we're sort of
not just criticizing the the theory and
the the deep facts or whatever it is of
the research but ultimately you're sort
of Chris criticizing some behavior on
the part of the research oh and they
said is well look some people this
person is on the academic job market at
the same time as me we weren't looking
at in the same jobs but some people said
well if you have this person at the same
level as you and you kind of criticize
them in this way it's gonna look like
you're kind of throwing elbows so you
don't want to have that perception about
you kind of state to stay away from it
other people said you know here's the
successful person sorry here's this
person who's a grad student
you know nobody likes it when you pick
on grad students and so what a tenured
faculty member might be told for
examples hey lay off he's a grad student
no don't don't pick on this poor
defenseless person the other hand people
said to me
they also say about people their more
senior in academia they say you know if
you do this it's just gonna look like
you want attention for yourself here's
this big study in science and you come
along wanting part of the action don't
you
and so everyone said you know if you do
this this is gonna have big negative
ramifications for you no matter how you
think about it Ian they also said what
if you're wrong and this was really the
thing that weighed on my mind even more
i had this evidence that I sort of was
worried about but I wasn't really sure
and the last thing you want to do is
tarnish someone's reputation or ruin
their career when they were kind of a
promising smart person who I knew
personally if you're wrong so I sort of
wasn't sure what to do about this this
is a kind of thing I like talked about
but not that actively at a lot of other
things to do is in the back of my mind
but eventually it came time for us to
actually do the follow-up study and when
we were trying to do it one thing that
had
and is we were having difficulty kind of
following sort of getting as many people
to do the surveys as he did in the
original study so I said well he had
this vendor you're not suppose to be
able to read the email so don't worry
about it
he he had this vendor that he used to
allegedly recruit people to these
surveys so why don't I go talk to this
vendor and ask the vendor hey can you do
what you did for me for him and I had
this email that was forwarded for me
from a few people where he said hey
here's what the vendor is going to do
and so I called up this vendor I say hey
there's this person Jason Peterson your
vice president of sampling and panel
recruitment can I talk to this person
because he did this big study for UCLA
I'd like to do it too you know whatever
it is UCLA bought that's what I need and
they all said you know we're a really
small company and no person with that
name has ever worked here that person
does not exist and then and we
definitely don't offer any of the
services like the ones described in this
email so I was like okay now in
combination with what I saw before and
all of a sudden I'm like a lot more
worried than before and ultimately what
happened is that I kind of went back to
the data with Josh callow my co-author
and then the help of Peter Aaron Oh
who's a professor at Yale and we spent
some time thinking about it and looking
at it not what this kind of like is this
we're really saying okay we need a
stress test this data now really look at
it what we eventually after lots of
twists and turns realized is you could
download a publicly available data set
from a National Survey run like two
lines of code and basically reproduce
exactly the data set that allegedly
created this paper so we saw that
basically we could simulate data they
looked exactly like the posted data in
the paper a little too easily
and eventually I sort of we sort of said
okay now we're pretty convinced there's
something here then and one of the
reasons why I'm so excited to talk to
you all today and hear your thoughts on
this is we I was sort of like what was
you next and my roommate actually was
the one who gave me the idea for how I
should think about this
he is the product of the University of
Washington computer science department
CTO of a company called hashey Corp and
he said you know we have this idea in
computer science called responsible
disclosure and the idea is that if you
say find out a way to hack Google you
don't just post that publicly you send a
private email to Google and you say hey
before I'd like say that I found this
bug publicly I want to give you some
time
fix it I want to give you advance notice
and that way kind of vulnerability can't
be exploited so to speak
yeah then after the fact you're kind of
transparent and you say after the bug is
fixed Google says hey this person found
the bug and here's this email chain we
had here's how it all went down just so
everybody knows and so he said and he
gave me some ideas about how we could
follow those same principles here so
what we did is we said okay the
vulnerability our knowledge that we
figured this out we realized that and we
had asked a lot of these kinds of
questions of of Michael before we
realized okay now that we really really
know we can't just go to him and say hey
we know you made up the data because we
knew that there were lots of things he
could do he was gonna keep making other
things up where he knew really had to
figure out the truth and so we had his
graduate adviser basically sit him down
on Monday morning and say okay you did
this big thing you supposedly got a
million dollars in grants ten thousand
you know survey responsible a lot do you
have like one receipt or like piece of
paper or piece of data or email or
anything from anybody any kind of paper
record of any kind indicating any of
this ever occurred and basically the
answer was no and then to try to be
transparent about it but after the
senior author on the paper realized that
the data was probably fabricated and
sent in a retraction we sort of came
forward and say hey this all just
happened and we want to be transparent
about the fact that we had a role in it
we had suspicions for a while and
thought here's what we found so there
was this retraction letter sent in by
the co-author of the of the paper and
then we posted this this on my website
we called irregularities in the in the
dataset we found it then blew up all
over the media it was kind of a crazy
thing and one of the most salient
takeaways from all of this media and
sanity that happened is is that to this
day I have fellow researchers come up to
me all the time or email me all the time
and say not oh it was so nice you did
that or you shouldn't be no matter
whatever the most common thing I hear is
hey me too I have this paper I've always
thought there was this big issue with
but I haven't known what to do about it
and this is what social scientists call
pluralistic ignorance when everyone
hopes that other people do something and
thinks it should be okay to do something
but expects that they should that people
wouldn't like it if they do it
themselves so everyone thinks
it would be nice I would like it if
other people told me their mistakes they
saw on the published record but they
expect that everyone else would judge
them negatively for it so people are
wrong about what other people think and
this is so pervasive that there's
actually this website psych file drawer
where people are supposed to post these
replications where if I replicate a
paper and find it doesn't work let's
just say hey I did this just so you guys
know they're having these issues where
people don't even want to say I did the
same study and I didn't find the effect
people are cowards sort of don't want to
admit to doing that so there's this
environment in academia right now where
people don't want to come forward so I
think this is bad and it puts us in the
kind of top circle of these nine circles
of hell which the author calls a limbo
and this is those of us who at any given
time are not committing one of the sins
below that are watching it all not doing
anything about it and so there's a lot
of us there and what I've learned is a
lot of people are there and don't want
to be there and and that's because this
status quo means that you know
researchers make mistakes innocent or
not and we kind of maybe talk about it
at conferences and there's kind of this
folk wisdom about the papers that kind
of everybody knows or wrong or that
nobody knows it wrong they should know
we're wrong authors can't respond to it
we can't really look into this and the
public doesn't really know so all the
people that fund our research fund these
buildings they never actually know what
we know about what research can be
believed in that so what I think is
academia might actually need some form
of what you might call responsible
disclosure the idea here being some way
of legitimate legitimate process I don't
know if I would have worked in my
particular case but in many of the cases
that I hear about legitimize a process
that would allow people to say I have
this concern about this published study
for example I think that they didn't
report everything and I want to look
into that and to do that we can't just
like exhort people if there's one thing
we know from social science and probably
convinced you we don't actually know all
that much one thing we do know is you
can't just tell people hey you should
behave this way and then hope they do
that will not work so we have to like
acknowledge some things that we wish
were not true and just say okay this is
the way the world is the way the world
is is criticizing peers is uncomfortable
reputation is the currency of academia
people want to look like good
researchers some important criticisms
don't really help that reputation
they're not deep or just hey I might
have found this error so people need
some kind of other
incentive to act and understanding
somebody else's data is not
straightforward so it's not so easy as
saying hey I found this error I want to
post publicly sometimes you often need
to do some communication so the idea I
have is for a kind of communication
system where you could imagine people
who find issues in published research or
think they found issues can talk to the
authors and try to figure out okay is
there an issue in this study and here's
what I have in mind
imagine that you write a paper and you
say you know I worry that I look at you
say I downloaded the replication data
and there's these other outcomes that
they don't discuss in the paper that
make the results look less good and so
I'm sort of worried that maybe the
results are not as strong as the
published record indicates and that the
public would think if they read it what
you could do is send an email to the
author through this system they would
say hey a person anonymous at the
beginning of the conversation a person
has a question for you and you could
sort of communicate back and forth in a
way that is confidential so the
conversation just like in the bug bounty
cases not being public you're talking
privately but the identity of the critic
is shielded so that way if in the worst
possible case there's no way the critic
the author could kind of exert
retribution we have no idea who the
critic is then two things can happen
either the critic could say okay now
back and forth you're hemming and hawing
I think I've actually found something
I'm at the point now where I'm willing
to go public and say here's this
conversation that now is going to be
retroactive Lee public everybody could
read and I'm willing to attach my name
to it and say I think I found this issue
everybody I think it's you know if
you're interested in this paper it's
worthwhile to read this email exchange
we had and that this third party can
verify we had the author can also say
this is malarkey I'm tired of being
harassed by this person whatever else
can't forcibly reveal the identity of
the critic and aside whoever you are
whatever issue you have I think I've
answered this I think people should know
we have this email exchange it's public
or some people have said they don't want
to be anonymous you could also say hey
here's Who I am by the way if you wanted
so the idea here yeah is that what the
technology would do is provide a third
party that could verify that a
conversation happened we're also
shielding the identity of the critic
unless the critic wants it to be open
but then verify that in fact was that
person that means that we have no
anonymous public
ism that means that we can figure out
the details before going public so you
can actually say hey what about this
what about that and kind of get the
facts that you often need to get in
these cases or the authors can also own
up and say oh yeah you're right which I
think a lot of people would do helps
protect critics from retribution that
way you're not that person who the
tenured professor will always know that
you're questioning their studies and try
to block you from getting jobs or
whatever else and also there's kind of a
bug bounty here if you actually find an
issue and then someone can say oh here's
the kind of person we should kind of
accrue some reputational rewards to this
person it was really good that they were
careful and went through the published
record found this issue and let us all
know about it and we can now attach that
to your name and kind of give you those
rewards yeah so there's no cell in which
in which basically the critic could
decide to make anonymous public
criticism only the author could decide
okay
basically the the critic knows that the
author can't forcibly reveal their
identity so if I email you and I wish
with your paper you can't say who is
this and like and Shamy or whatever else
but you could decide okay I think this
is a meritless accusation or you could
even decide oh you know I think this is
you know many people might have this
question about my paper but I think it
checks out so I'm willing to you know
have this out there some people know but
that's the idea yes the the author can
never kind of forcibly reveal the critic
but the critic can't just anonymously
publicly say here here are these issues
that's the idea
and the goals here are to sort of
increase the incentives for reporting
flaws there's probably some optimal
level of how much of this there goes on
we don't want every paper dealing with
this all day every day but I would say
probably based on the fact that majority
of what we do is not true means that
we're not doing enough of this right now
I think we need more incentives for
doing that on the other hand we want to
protect innocent researchers from kind
of incorrect or anonymous accusations
and then also increase the public
accessibility of this knowledge so it's
not just the kind of thing where you get
to graduate school and as I did you hear
in your first-year seminars Oh everybody
knows that paper doesn't actually work
this is actually something that those
who don't attend elite graduate programs
could know about and and
the idea of first kind of the indirect
effect is if you're an author thinking
of doing one of these things you're
going to say oh man that systems out
there it might catch me one day and it
also kind of increases the value of
those transparency tools so now all of a
sudden all that replication data that's
been posted that people have gone
through the effort to post becomes a lot
more valuable if we know that there's a
system for actually vetting it so we're
in Silicon Valley obviously so every
every idea needs to be solved by a beta
a piece of software and so obviously
that's what it here here it is that I'm
here to do is not just to get your
comments that I'm really interested in
but also try to solicit your help in
building this so this is something where
when I talk to a lot of people in social
science they say here's papers one two
three four five like I need this for I
need some way to do this and this would
provide any kind of an institution a
legitimized way to express the concerns
that I have so there's a lot of demand
out there for something like this right
now I'm sure that the ideas I have are
not perfect and you all have a lot more
experience thinking about how it is that
people kind of interact with systems
like this the incentives there so I'm
very interested to hear your comments
but you also have the expertise to
actually think about how to build
something like this and so part of where
I'm here to say is that if you're
interested in that you should come talk
to me about it because we have money and
are ready to actually pay somebody to
build this thing and the idea would be
to beta test it basically start with a
class start with a couple classes and
say let's work out the kinks let's see
if this is actually a terrible idea
let's see if it's abuse let's see what
happens if this actually produces useful
results or not and that's where we kind
of want to start so part of why I'm here
today is to get your comments and part
of is to recruit you and so that's where
we are and sure there's lots of
questions
guess lady authors or dissipate this
right isn't it like it like I published
it wants to move on and they can just
safely ignore yeah the idea would be
that if you're the author what you know
so so here D the idea suppose that
you're dishonest author and you get one
of these emails saying hey this
anonymous person says they look at your
data set and they feel like your
findings are not actually all that
robust one thing you could do is say all
right I'm just gonna not respond I think
then the idea is what the credit could
do is say hey will you respond hey we'll
your spot and eventually say okay it's
been six months since I originally wrote
to you you haven't responded at this
point I'm gonna basically take your
silence as an admission of guilt or
something like that and the credit could
basically say even if the author doesn't
agree the critic has the option in the
second row of saying look I'm pushing
this conversation public this is at the
point where I feel like other people
should know you're not responding to
this and so knowing that that might
happen the idea is that the author would
say well I don't want to be kind of
shown as one of these people who like
never responds to questions about their
research so I'm gonna respond oftentimes
like honest authors will also like not
like respond because just like a large
amount it's a norm that like person not
respond like if it's normally like by
volunteering to participate the system
I have clenched myself that every email
I ever get a response to prompt is
hopefully you don't get to decide you
know if you say oh I'm just never gonna
check my email inbox again then
eventually if people are doing this to
you then all of your colleagues gonna
say it's mighty weird that so-and-so has
all these people that have been trying
to email him about issues in his studies
and he or she never wrote back to any of
them so that's the idea is it kind of
uses the fact that in academia there's
this like social pressure to kind of
defend your work and comply with norms
and be honest to say okay everybody else
is going to watch the fact that I'm not
responding and kind of judge me
negatively that's going to
compel me to do it the idea is kind of
leverage that leverage that social
pressure that it would happen there is
then the question of like the false
positive of now what if someone like
there are in fact many academics who are
just so busy so I think one thing you do
for example like imagine if like so I'm
you know going this weekend up to Point
Reyes that I'm flying to Denver on
Monday if someone said you know I want
an answer immediately I think I would
just respond on the system and say like
I'm busy the question you have is gonna
take me some time to look into you know
it's a good question or not you know
give me a couple months and I think this
is the kind of thing where as the kind
of administrators of the system we don't
have to kind of decide what the norms
should be I think leave it in the hands
of people to say you know if all of
sudden some critic says that's not good
enough you know screw you David like you
didn't respond in 24 hours with a full
data file then I think I would say you
know I'm pretty sure anybody's reading
this is gonna think that I acted
reasonably and like here's why and you
know give me a few weeks so I think the
idea is to say you know all this is is
kind of the very like basic kind of
tools of kind of an audited conversation
and the option for you know private
anonymity and then the social norms can
have build around that where people can
figure out okay well what's what is kind
of a reasonable use of this or or nor
not good hope yeah social system is the
deleterious effects of an antisocial
behavior relative to the positive
effects of pro-social behavior so
Wikipedia works because it's far faster
to reverse bad changes than it is to
generate that change for example and
there was a group there's a really
wonderful terrible example depending on
your point of view
I used to San Diego where they were
trying to crowdsource sunlight
reassembly of a shredded document and
they came in and they basically moved
everything around and you know it
totally
nutes the the effect because it was much
easier to mess it up than it was to
freeze
so what I'm thinking about here is how
much harm a single individual could have
on sort of the socio technical system
yeah and whether there are ways to
mitigate that so from that so men for a
minute that like Gaza publishes papers
and I'm just a troll yeah and I'm just
basically sort of picking off right
papers and throwing basically meritless
accusations at but ones that are
essentially causing a lot of effort to
be spent on behalf of the audience so
I'm wondering if there are ways in the
system to shadow ban or held a an or
something these people yeah that would
essentially reduce that incentive to
troll people yeah good question so a few
ideas have had on that front and I'm
sure many more so one is that I think to
use this you'd probably want to have
something where there's an indication if
like somebody's email address is like
edu or not not that like valid criticism
can't come from not die edu domains but
that would kind of give you some signal
another would be that people could you
know there's probably some like report
option I think also authors could say
you know this is the 10th one of these
I've gotten from somebody this week you
know I think this is harassment you know
if I hear from somebody else I'm happy
to do this but you know here's my
judgment of the situation so I think
it's just on extent you could allow
authors just sort of call it out because
part of what I'm thinking about is like
ways to create a little overhead as
possible so that there's not like some
body that has to decide if this is is
happening but you know some excited
that's always gonna be unavoidable
pretend to be a new student social
science you know sitting with a lot of
economists would be make people pay $5
just say hey that's not that much but if
you want to do you know they're really
worth a thousand dollars to you to like
be a troll them yeah those kind of small
costs can treat our people maybe yeah
yes for an incredibly expensive in
go back and fix like try to do the study
again and if so where were they secure
the funding for that yeah so it really
depends on the so a lot of the work that
I do for example is really cheap so I
don't need to go get grants for it I'm
doing you know super cheap survey is
collecting existing data working with
groups that already paying for something
whatever else in other in other cases is
really expensive so I think the idea
would be a few things one is obviously
there is like some level of like
embarrassment that occurs and I think
like why is that like a good thing
partly is because it's not just about
like what happens in this you know that
you can observe but it's like the effect
that people know this might be coming so
in some sense part of the hope of like
the biggest effect will not actually be
what happens that you can directly
observe in such a system but rather what
a researcher who knows this system
exists will do so the idea is okay I
know that I might be embarrassed if I
don't like follow like some honest
procedures or I'm not careful so now I
should like not do the things that will
lead that to happen so I would say
that's actually goal number one there's
the kind of reaction the kind of
anticipated reaction to that we would
call an equilibrium effect in social
science I think in terms of what would
happen in a particular case there's a
lot of things that could happen one
thing that could be depending on the
severity error papers can be kind of
there's this thing called core addendum
or never know how to pronounce it where
you can sort of say okay you know this
table was wrong or papers can be
retracted people can you know submit
amendments there's lots and lots of ways
in which kind of journals deal with this
that one could imagine and depending on
the kind of study hopefully other people
would would do it again so and you could
imagine the kind of thing where on a
given paper once it's kind of public
that there's some issue about it and the
kind of threat has been made public I
thought about maybe other people could
then go comment and say oh well I saw
this thread and then did a replication
and like here's what I found I think
those who just bought bonds so somebody
with negative ratings just yet
I'm somebody write to a bull with email
as long as identities are have some
expense whether it's social or financial
like intellectual property say I like to
say that I've seen air in your paper and
I think you should have done it this way
you know like okay see nothing you do do
it that way like would you have to put
my face like what I be giving credit in
some way or like what I mean like a very
prominent way in which this happens in
academia which is anonymous peer review
when people if you submit a paper for
publication in many cases though not all
cases through reviewers don't know who
you are but also almost always when you
get their reviews back to say the
shooter should not be published you
don't know who the reviewers are so we
already kind of recognize in academia
and deal with this problem of sometimes
people have ideas that you don't know
who they are and typically what people
will do is like footnote like I
acknowledge an anonymous reviewer for
you know giving me this idea or
something like that one thing that is a
good question though and one thing it
doesn't make it worry about is you know
to what extent what people kind of
censor themselves because you know they
want to get credit for some idea but I
guess my view is in that case they can
that kind of person who feels like they
have some and a publishable idea that it
kind of rises to levels because that
there is kind of real intellectual
property there that kind of idea already
has a way of being expressed in academia
which is what you go publish it
whereas what I'm more worried about is
these kind of smaller issues where it's
not an you know a big intellectual
contribution of the size that clears the
bar for like a journal article to say
this paper wasn't honest but you still
want some way of incentivizing people to
make that known yeah yeah another big
problem with academic integrity is that
protracted paper to continue to be cited
yes as if they hadn't been retracted as
did you extend your system to also solve
that problem wow that's a good question
it is true and it's amazing and crazy
I don't know do you me ideas on top
about that earth well I I guess a big
part of it is like media and
communications and I'm not an expert on
that kind of thing but it it's hard to
track down whether or not the paper has
been retracted or not
and so when you glanced over it it makes
your paper look much more credible and
you don't so I don't know but it could
involve some kind of communicating that
it has been retracted better yes is that
oftentimes you'll see you know someone
will write in their academic paper well
you know building on you know if
assuming X is true where X is something
that has been learned to be not true and
then you build some other claim from
that and and and a lot of that happens
weirdly so I think the I don't notice
all that problem other than like the
very boring thing of like journals need
to update their websites better or their
PDFs or something but in terms of like
what is the theory of like how people
would happen upon this information I
think the goal would be that like
oftentimes in in these situations like
okay so in the case of the the lacor
thing literally I just I didn't like
announce this to anybody like we had had
this thing the retraction was sent at a
science and we were like we just want to
be transparent about our involvement in
this I literally just put like a small
print a link at the bottom of my website
that like linked to this PDF document
and like then by the next day I mean I
have no idea like how it got out in
there because I didn't like advertise it
I just put it down there and like by the
next morning it was like everywhere so
which means what I expected happen to be
clear but but at the very least I think
there's like ways in which like people
who care enough about something will
like go talk about it and in the like
kind of small communities of researchers
that work in particular areas in this
system is people saying oh you sighted
this thing that is if somebody you know
the interpretation of somebody's results
is really built on some other you know
more basic claim being true you could
imagine it being like another kind of
it's not error in data that's got air
and reasoning or something like that
and one for that question
yeah systems don't have to satisfy every
use case one that I feel like maybe
you've made a conscious or a conscious
decision to leave out is the friends
having friends phenomenon so let's say
that you and I are friends and let's
let's say that guys and I are friends
and gives uh things that has seen
evidence that he thinks I've been acting
unethically about okay that's right this
is a scenario where if you follow this
chart what would end up happening it's
it you know he says I know well I found
this irregularity in your data because
I'm there because I knew about it
because I could sort of see what's going
on right then that goes public delivered
him to make it go public is to also out
himself to me yeah when we know that
many of these like in the history of
people being outed yeah right
they're actually closed like we just set
that aside or there are other ways to
deal with that yeah so lots that don't
directly answer that you know I think to
some extent Akademi deals with that now
a bit in the sense that you know I at
least half the papers I review I know
who they're by because I've seen them
before and they're like people that I
know would like and would consider my
friends and that's just kind of an oil
part of it and people feel like already
you know there might be some bias there
but I think people are at least somewhat
accustomed to academia I've liked doing
that there is this level at which if it
rises to a kind of more serious like
honesty issue and I think the way I
think about that is this you know if you
go in and this is what I actually think
this is not a good this would not have
helped like my particular case it was
just like what my case opened my my eyes
to if there's something like really
serious like that or you know if you're
right is gonna be very serious and I
think probably in this case we this time
pressure because this other study and
this other people's money we were
spending that we had to like know if
this is right or not and
the public stuff and whatever but I
think in more typical cases what would
happen is you would go through kind of
the academic honesty Channel so you
would imagine like you know one of you
would go to like a Dean and say this
should be investigated or you would kind
of go through the you know channels of
the university and like our employers
and supervisors and have those channels
would be the ones you'd probably prefer
in many of those cases with that said I
think one way in which that does make
the real-world version of that problem
easier though is you could easily
imagine a situation where for example a
lot of people don't post their
replication data online but they will
email it out and so right now we're in a
situation where imagine you know there's
some author you want to write to and
there's some paper that you feel like
that person only gets requests for the
replication data maybe once a year and
you think there might be an issue with
the paper if you write into that person
and say okay well you know I want to see
your data and then a few months later or
magically some person comes out of the
ether saying looking at your data I'll
have this concern it's gonna be obvious
that's you so I think one extension to
this that definitely is necessary is I
think it should become potentially a
norm if if this in fact is a good idea
that you know right from the beginning
even if you don't suspect anything is
wrong this is the mechanism by which you
ask for replication data so if it's I'm
just saying hey here's an anonymous
email from edu address saying I want the
replication data not because I think
there's anything wrong but just because
that way in case I do find something you
can't say aha
that's the only person that asked for my
data it was probably them so really
really interesting stuff and I'm
wondering you know in the previous
studies that you showed earlier on it
seems like this is you know a rampant
problem right all right or at least you
know fairly large right and so I'm
wondering and the system you're
proposing seems like it's really good at
catching or creating some incentives to
do this after it's been published but as
you you know mentioned a we have in
theory a system inside academia to try
to catch problems ahead of time peer
review and so I'm wondering have you
thought at all and to me
it seems like you know if the previous
studies you know as indicated it seems
like we have a big problem with peer
peer review right now and you know as a
peer reviewer I think you know we just
get so many there's so many papers and
as it seems like there's sort of this
you know arms race and academia to
publish more and more paper there's
still not as many academics and we have
this issue and this is a lot you know
topic that comes up a lot in program
committee meetings and these things
actually fix this problem of peer review
in that you know you can have a
reasonable amount of time and give each
paper a really solid look so I'm
wondering if you've thought it all about
like how do we make that better or is it
just that we need to have some you know
post hoc solution that can then use the
wisdom of so many more people we're
gonna read the paper yeah many people
way smarter than me for much longer than
I have about how to make peer review
better and know just because it's not a
perfect system doesn't mean it's not you
know better than nothing right so I
don't know that I've any anything
insightful to say off the top of my head
about it
what I will say is that I'm definitely
thinking along those lines is what
inspired the kind of fourth row of the
table here the idea being if you're a
peer reviewer you know why write a
careful review really you know besides
kind of the ethical do to yourself and
it's kind of really academic inside
baseball for those who don't live in
this world the only reason is like if
you're writing a peer review the people
the only person who reads it with your
name attached to it is the editor of the
journal so if you write a totally stupid
peer review or not a careful peer review
or you know on the other hand if you're
thinking about putting in the effort to
write a really good peer review the only
person in whose eyes those are
reputational benefits accrue is the is
the editor of that journal so it's a
kind of a pretty small payoff so the
idea here is part of the the bug bounty
here is is is this last row which is to
say you know is a peer reviewer you just
don't have the incentive to be careful
and I think it would be really hard to
to figure out a way to do that so it can
incentivize anonymous peer reviewers to
to be more careful but when you're doing
public criticized
or sorry another 4th row the second row
if you're doing public criticism and you
say okay well hey I think and and we all
agree you know being careful and reading
a paper and seeing it has an issue and
following up on it that's like a good
thing that means we should think more of
you if like that's the thing we all
agree on in the context of this you know
legitimized thing then all of a sudden
somebody might feel like they have an
incentive to go the extra mile so I mean
again even though I don't think it's the
best the best example of this you know
the the the data for this paper that
looks like that looked like this you
know this was data that a lot of people
worked with okay so you know there was
there's a couple follow-up Papers
written on like methodological things in
the state or whatever else so a lot of
people spend a lot of time with this
data this is part of why for me I said
so littles I was like a lot of other
people have looked at this data and they
haven't you know decided to go forward
so you know why should I think that I
know better than they do this seems
weird but they're not concerned what you
know so I think one thing that you know
that you know this shows you is that a
lot of people can look at a lot of
things and miss stuff and really part of
what it takes is you know lowering the
activation energy so someone says like
hey this seems weird can you explain
this so that it's a little easier to
kind of get the chain of dominoes
rolling
you